We ended at the following iteration.
We looked at how linear regression performed on our initial feature set and
decided to reduce the feature set to a simpler selection, specifically the top
three performing features, Hershey's, Kit Kat, and Airheads.
Simpler models are usually more effective.
Than complex models.
In particular, reducing the number of features as much as possible to
those that matter most is almost always beneficial.
Moreover, lower numbers of features avoid the curse of dimensionality.
Which is something that we'll talk about much more later on this course.
Let's now evaluate the newer model with the reduced feature set.
And in this plot just as before, the green line refers to
the true inter selection time and the blue line refers to our model.
Now, in this model.
Our predictors using less information to predict the demand for Starburst.
You can see here the result of doing so.
Notice that our predicted line is a bit less jagged than the line that
uses all of the features.
Which indicates that we're over-fitting less.
Revising the feature set choice from the question phase successfully resulted in
reducing overfitting.
We can also see now the new means square error of our new model.
Now let's make a plot on the test set.
The overfitting issue has been somewhat resolved, but now we need to
examine the issue of our model missing the spikes in interselection time.
Clearly this time we cannot avoid having to make a different choice at
the model phase